[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kreisel
berichte und christian sievers
guten arbeit in allen terminkalender in
der politik sind immer knallvoll aber
was armin laschet heute auf dem plan hat
ist noch mal eine extra kategorie auf
der einen seite empfiehlt er heute einen
nachfolger für sich selbst als
ministerpräsident und cdu-landeschef in
nordrhein-westfalen
auf der anderen seite sucht er in berlin
händeringend nach einer neuen regierung
für dieses land an der cdu csu beteiligt
sind mindestens ebenso händeringend
sucht er nach einem neuen amt für sich
selbst kanzler oder abseits selten war
die auswahl so atemberaubend weit
auseinander das gespräch mit den grünen
heute musste aus laschet sicht gelingen
sonst wäre auch diese chance für ihn
vertan noch bevor sie sich so richtig
eröffnet hat patricia wiedemeier jetzt
über einen besonderen tag in berlin und
in düsseldorf
es scheint als wollten grüne und union
gleich mal zu beginn zeigen wohin die
reise gehen soll treffpunkt heute das
europäische energie forum ein zukunfts
ort mitten in berlin hier arbeiten 5000
menschen rund um die themen mobilität
und nachhaltigkeit es ist ein einziges
real labor der energiewende aber ist
deutlich mehr klimaschutz die
vielzitierte ökologische transformation
mit der union machbar es ist zumindest
das thema beim heutigen treffen bei dem
es die meisten übereinstimmungen gehabt
so viel wurde anschließend verraten es
gab viele punkte wo man sich gut
angenähert hat ich glaube der wichtigste
und weitreichendste ist das thema klima
bei einer transformation für unser land
auch bei der mitnahme von
wirtschaftlicher und sozialer
interessenausgleich zu finden war
überfiel gemeinsamkeiten gefunden man
könne an die erfahrungen von 2017 an die
jamaika verhandlungen anknüpfen so armin
laschet er kämpft weiter für ein bündnis
aus union grünen und fdp und eine absage
an jamaika gab es heute nicht die union
jedenfalls ist bereit diese grundidee
einer modernisierung des landes tempo zu
machen dass sie den wichtigen die mitte
unterstützen und weiter gespräche zu
führen ein sehr offenes intensives
gespräch sei es gewesen betonten alle
vier aber nicht nur bei den themen
migration und finanzen gibt es weiter
differenzen
denn klar ist in gerade
gesellschaftspolitischen bereichen
stehen unsere parteien er weiter
auseinander darüber haben wir auch
gesprochen was es für differenzen gibt
und in anderen bereichen gibt es
entsprechend auch gemeinsame anliegen
wie die modernisierung unseres landes
die fdp und wir werden sicherlich jetzt
die gespräche insgesamt in den gremien
bewerten also nicht jedes gespräch
einzel nur sondern auch im abgleich
dessen was möglich ist für eine nächste
regierung in deutschland schon morgen
wollen grüne und auch fdp jeder für sich
beraten wie es nun weitergeht wer mit
wem als nächstes sprechen wird für armin
laschet ging es anschließend weiter nach
düsseldorf in die landtagsfraktionen
auch hier müssen weichen gestellt werden
schon vor der wahl hatte er angekündigt
nicht ministerpräsident in düsseldorf zu
bleiben sein nachfolger soll der
nordrhein-westfälische verkehrsminister
wüst werden ob er wehmut empfindet beim
abschied von nrw habe versucht unser
land europäisch aufzustellen in seiner
vielfalt zu prägen so dass mir das spaß
gemacht hat wissen sie
was schöner ist das ist nun ohnehin
stand ja nie zur debatte des aachen
schöner ist als berlin aber der
arbeitsort berlin hat halt ein paar
institutionen die in aachen ich sind und
deshalb werde ich dann eine einige tage
meines lebens in berlin verbringen nur
tage wie lange er am ende wirklich in
berlin bleibt das ist auch heute neun
tage nach der wahl offen ein
rückfahrschein nach nordrhein westfalen
hat armin laschet aber nicht mehr
[Applaus]
aber treue ist der nrw-innenminister und
parteifreund von armin laschet heraus
guten abend schön nannte sie was sie
bekommen jetzt einen neuen
ministerpräsidenten in düsseldorf warum
muss armin laschet auch das jetzt quasi
noch so nebenbei regeln hätte er nicht
im sommer quasi sagen herr wüst wird
mein nachfolger es gibt ja leute die
haben den verdacht dass er sich da eine
hintertür offen gehalten hat mit
sicherheit nicht ja das war abgesprochen
zwischen allen beteiligten und das war
auch klug so diesen schritt zu gehen und
dass er sich jetzt um kümmert sowieso
ebene der kümmert sich um die anliegen
der nimmt seine aufgaben wahr und
flüchtet sich kümmert sich aber er hat
ja unfassbar viel zu tun er versucht ja
nebenbei quasi auch noch eine
jamaika-koalition irgendwie zustande zu
bekommen wie groß ist denn aus ihrer
sicht die gefahr dass laschet am ende
ohne jedes amt da steht ja das kann ich
nicht beurteilen er selber übrigens auch
nicht und das ist in der politik oder es
kann sein aber er hat doch jetzt die
pflicht dafür zu sorgen
für eine gute regierung für deutschland
zu sorgen und wenn es da eine chance
gibt muss er sich darum kümmern und auch
ordentlich verhandeln und das macht er
würde ich mir manchmal wünschen dass er
da auch mehr unterstützung bei bekäme
kommen wir gleich noch zu sagen er macht
das wenn es eine chance gibt für wie
groß würden sie denn diese chance
einschätzen die diese bands die sie
verwenden erroll klingen jetzt sind
nicht gerade nach aufbruch nach nach
vorne diskutieren ja ich meine wir sind
wir haben eine niederlage erlitten wir
sind weil wir uns selber zerstritten
haben für die leute nicht besonders
attraktiv gewesen wir sind jetzt zweiter
platz und damit muss man dann auch
ordentlich umgehen auf der anderen seite
haben fast 25 prozent der menschen uns
gewählt das heißt wir können doch nicht
einfach sagen wir fliegen jetzt wir
kümmern uns nicht und das ist das was
jetzt passiert miteinander diskutieren
ausloten und ob und wie das funktioniert
ich bin ja kein hellseher kann ich ihnen
auch nicht verraten das hängt von vielen
faktoren ab und das ist natürlich sehr
stark in der hand der fdp und auch der
grünen die jetzt stark sind und die am
ende entscheiden mit wem sie lieber
regieren mit dem sie lieber zukunft
gestalten jetzt haben sie gesagt er
armin laschet hätte mehr unterstützung
aus den eigenen reihen verdient wie man
sie das ich finde wenn man so ein
auftrag wenn man sich so eine aufgabe
nimmt und sagt wir versuchen für unser
land eine gute regierung hinzubekommen
eine bessere als die andere alternative
dann ist es nicht sehr hilfreich wenn
eigene kollegen einem in den rücken
fallen oder wenn darüber diskutiert wird
wann wie wo haben mit laschet seine
aufgaben seine ämter abgeben muss wer
wann wie wo welche ämter kriegt also
erstens interessierte leute überhaupt
nicht wie wir unsere ämter verteilen und
zweitens stellt es solche verhandlungen
das erhöht nicht die glaubwürdigkeit für
denjenigen der da verhandelt ich finde
das stimmt aber kann es denn sein dass
jemand der schon im eigenen laden soll
ich jetzt mal salopp so unter feuer
steht am ende kanzler von deutschland
wird es kann aber umgekehrt auch nicht
sein dass störer menschen die irgendwie
für sich eine andere karriere geplant
haben jetzt ein werk zerstören was mehr
ist als die frage wer wird was es geht
nicht um die frage ob armin laschet
kanzler wird oder nicht sonst geht darum
welche politische richtung in zukunft
bestimmt welche konstellation denn
darüber dann wirklich entschieden wie
die vier jahren die politik in
deutschland gemacht wird ist ja nicht so
ganz unwichtig und wenn man eine chance
hat darauf einfluss zu nehmen denn finde
es unverantwortlich wenn wir das nicht
nutzen würde das heißt sie fern es auch
okay wenn jemand anderes aus der cdu
oder csu am ende kanzler wurde und eben
nicht armin laschet neben diesen ganzen
spielereien beschäftige ich mich
überhaupt nicht weil sie unsinnig sind
weil sie stören und die entscheidung ist
klar getroffen wir haben ihn zum
kanzlerkandidaten gemacht manchmal auch
in der demokratie mit mehrheit dann ist
aber die mehrheit ist immer der sieger
jetzt nehme ich an dass armin laschet
selbst doch gerne kanzler werden möchte
alles andere wäre ja auch wahnsinn aus
seiner sicht jetzt ist es so dass auch
schon heute wieder an die öffentlichkeit
dringt was in diesen vor
sondierungsgesprächen intern gesagt wird
das schadet natürlich laschet ganz
besonders was sagt denn dass
überlastschutz führungsstärke ja gar nix
das sagt etwas aus über die schwäche
oder die die disziplinlosigkeit der
anderen ich meine wie so ist der schuld
der den laden zusammenhält der sich
aufopfert der stunden investiert weil
die sache geht während andere
nachrichten nach hause schicken also die
frage müsste man nämlich denjenigen
stellen die so unsolidarisch unterwegs
sind er ist der moderator heißt es immer
wieder einer der vor unterschiedliche
interessen gut unter einen hut bringen
kann hat er irgendwas in der hand was
ihm jetzt hilft jamaika schmieden zu
können also doch ich glaube das war
seine hand hat ist er selber ist seine
art und weise mit leuten umzugehen die
erfahrung die wir hier in düsseldorf
gehabt haben wie man auch mit kleineren
partnern umgeht fragen sie mal die fdp
in nordrhein-westfalen wie dieser
regierung stil war wie erfolgreich er
war und wie angenehm er war ich habe in
manchen gräben in gesetzen ich kann
ihnen sagen in diesem kabinett
mitzuarbeiten war eine wirkliche freude
weil es ein spiel war er anders war als
man oft in der politik erlebt das ist
schade dass es jetzt verloren geht herr
all das klingt jetzt auch schon wie so
ein bisschen wie ein abgesang der armin
laschet muss sehr sehr viel einstecken
im moment hat uns ganz klar steckt eine
ganze menge ein haben sie manchmal so
ein bisschen mitleid mit ihm
das ist das falsche wort da führe ich
finds schade ich finde es unanständig
von anderen armen ist manns genug das
durchzuhalten dann bin ich ganz sicher
aber fair ist das nicht wie wir
miteinander umgehen aber die frage
müssen die beantworten die sich zu
verhalten und nicht der armin laschet er
einfach seinen weg geht der sich kümmert
und der versucht antworten zu finden
unter falling lösung so patrol der
cdu-innenminister in nordrhein-westfalen
harry vielen dank für das gespräch heute
und dem heute journal bedanke mich auch
so und jetzt kommen bei in der sendung
zu einem komplett anderen thema was ist
für kinder in frankreich nach der
familie und dem freundeskreis der ort
mit dem höchsten risiko opfer von
sexueller gewalt zu werden die
katholische kirche so steht das in der
studie einer unabhängigen
untersuchungskommission deren ergebnisse
erschrecken seit 1950 gab es danach
hunderttausende
minderjährige missbrauchsopfer in der
kirche viele mädchen der weit
überwiegende anteil jungen im alter von
zehn bis 13 jahren der skandal der
katholischen kirche geht weit über
frankreich hinaus deutsche opfer
verbände sehen verstörende parallelen
wie in deutschland seien auch in
frankreich die täter geschützt und die
opfer klein gehalten worden anders als
in deutschland habe man in frankreich
aber wenigstens nicht der kirche die
aufarbeitung selbst überlassen crystal
hat
sie nennen es das gebäude der schande
so france war so rené und josef sind an
den ort zurückgekehrt der sie für immer
gezeichnet hat ein katholisches internat
[Applaus]
wir hatten einen seelsorger der uns die
bei spielern jedes mal viel an uns zu
streicheln und dann lagen wir in seinem
bett das nebenan stand julia gibt
es sind wahr gewordene albträume die sie
erlebt haben sie waren gerade mal zehn
jahre alt
der geistliche hat meine hose
aufgeknüpft und seine hand in meinen
slip geschoben und für eine gefühlte
ewigkeit hatte mit meinen genitalien
gespielt
drei opfer von
216.000 die seit 1950 als kinder sexuell
missbraucht worden von priestern
ordensleuten und anderen geistlichen der
untersuchungsbericht der heute
vorgestellt wurde stellt die katholische
kirche frankreichs schonungslos an den
pranger
es gab eine kollektive fahrlässigkeit
ein versagen ein verschweigen es gab
eine institutionelle vertuschung die
systemischen charakter hat
charaktersystem liegt die kirche und der
sexuelle missbrauch zwei jahre lang
prüfte die untersuchungskommission akten
hörte opfer und täter die kirche hatte
ihre archive geöffnet als zeichen der
kooperation das was da ans tageslicht
kam die skrupellosigkeit die
gleichgültigkeit schockiert selbst die
opfer die heute anwesend waren
sie sind eine schande für die menschheit
sie müssen für jedes dieser verbrechen
zahlen do is dream
an diesem bericht wird die katholische
kirche schwer zu tragen haben er schäme
sich sagt der vorsitzende der
bischofskonferenz
modernisierungs mein wunsch ist es sie
heute um verzeihung zu bitten ich bitte
alle um entschuldigung
das wird nicht reichen nicht nur die
untersuchungskommission fordert
entschädigungen prävention und absolute
transparenz die drei männer vor dem
internat sagen von sich selbst sie seien
lebendige tote das was die kirche ihnen
angetan hat lässt sich wohl nie wieder
gutmachen
mehr darüber wie lange die aufarbeitung
von sexualisierter gewalt in der
katholischen kirche in frankreich schon
dauert das finden sie bei uns online auf
zdf heute und jetzt macht hier kein
server weiter mit einem ersten
nachrichtenüberblick in sachsen ist die
extremistische szene deutlich größer und
radikaler geworden das zeigt der
aktuelle verfassungsschutzbericht
vor allem die zahl der rechtsextremisten
habe 2020 zugenommen von 3400 auf 4800
hintergrund sei die frühere alf die
organisation der flügel die seit gut
anderthalb jahren vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet wird und in sachsen als
gesinnungsgemeinschaft weiterlebe
gewachsen sei auch die
linksextremistische szene an beiden
rändern sinke außerdem die hemmschwelle
zu gewalt in slowenien sind die staats
und regierungschefs der eu
zusammengekommen zu ihrem ersten gipfel
seit der jüngsten afghanistan krise bei
einem abendessen sprechen sie auch über
andere außenpolitische themen so geht es
um eine größere eigenständigkeit europas
auch militärisch um den umgang mit china
und den geplatzten französischen modell
mit australien am rande wurde
bundeskanzlerin merkel mit dem höchsten
slowenischen verdienstorden geehrt
in rumänien spitzt sich die politische
krise zu mit einem misstrauensvotum hat
das parlament ministerpräsident floor in
kittsee abgesetzt hintergrund ist die
entlassung zweier minister damit hatte
kids so den ausstieg eines
koalitionspartners provoziert rumänien
droht nun eine längere phase der
instabilität
möglicherweise gibt es neuwahlen
unicef meldet erschreckende zahlen
demnach leidet jeder siebte junge mensch
zwischen 10 und 19 unter einer
diagnostizierten psychischen störung
weltweit nehmen sich jährlich rund
46.000 heranwachsende das leben durch
die krone pandemie habe sich das problem
verschärft die seelischen auswirkungen
werde man noch jahre spüren gleichzeitig
gebe es viel zu wenig hilfsangebote
zwei wochen nach seinem ausbruch wird
der vulkan auf la palma wieder aktiver
er schleudert fußballgroße lava klumpen
in die höhe so genannte bomben gestern
war sein krater teilweise eingestürzt
aus einem inneren ergießt sich nun ein
lover sie über bereits zerstörte gebiete
rund 1000 gebäude wurden von den massen
begraben außerdem bildete sich an der
atlantikküste 1 33 hektar großes plateau
gastarbeiter in dem wort liegt schon das
ganze missverständnis menschen die zum
arbeiten kommen sollen aber eben als
gäste die dann auch wieder gehen seit
genau 60 jahren gibt es das deutsch
türkische anwerbeabkommen
der bundespräsident erinnerte deshalb
heute an den irrtum auf beiden seiten
der mit ihm begann die einen wollten ein
paar jahre bleiben geld ansparen und
dann kam das leben dazwischen
auf der anderen seite sei die deutsche
gesellschaft lange nicht bereit gewesen
ihre perspektive auf die gastarbeiter zu
verändern wir riefen arbeitskräfte es
kamen menschen hat der schriftsteller
max frisch mal gesagt deren kinder und
enkel sind eben nicht menschen mit
migrationshintergrund so schreibt frank
walter steinmeier das seinen bürgerinnen
und bürgern heute ins stammbuch vielmehr
sei deutschland ein land mit
migrationshintergrund geworden dort
ferber zeigt es uns
er kam als gastarbeiter da war er mitte
20 jetzt ist die als zehn kai dieses
rentner und lebt noch immer in duisburg
auch seine erwachsenen söhne die enkel
ein leben das so geplant war
es wurden 48 jahre deutschland das war
arbeit später auch familie ein
deutsch-türkisches leben mit vielen
herausforderungen
allein
acht und der schweiz
800.000 türken wie kai dieses brachte
das anwerbeabkommen nach deutschland sie
schufteten im bergbau und an
fließbändern und wikis blieben viele
bekamen kinder und enkel
3 millionen türkeistämmige leben
inzwischen in deutschland
ihre geschichte ist eine deutsche
geschichte zeigt diese ausstellung in
essen und ihr fleiß und ihre
leidenschaft haben das land zu dem
gemacht was es heute ist sagte der
bundespräsident beim festakt zum
sechzigsten jahrestag des
anwerbeabkommens
ihre kinder und enkel die bauen jetzt an
diesem deutschland weiter und wir
brauchen sie dabei sie sind
handwerker künstlerinnen und musiker
unternehmerinnen impfstoffentwickler
richterinnen und staatsanwälte
abgeordnete staatssekretären oder
minister sie sind häufig deutsche
staatsbürgerinnen und staatsbürger sie
sind eben nicht menschen mit
migrationshintergrund sondern in
deutschland ist ein land mit
migrationshintergrund geworden und es
ist höchst zeit dass wir uns dazu
bekennen
ein land mit migrationshintergrund das
ist auch das deutsch-türkische leben der
familie kai dieses in duisburg so ein
meter hahn hat hier gerade viel
investiert eine neue halle für seine kfz
werkstatt mit mehreren mitarbeitern
ich tue das beste draus sagen
und vater jelzin ist stolz auf das leben
mit der gastarbeiter geschichte da sich
auf diese weise entwickelt hat
familie kein gesetz hat ihren platz
gefunden in ihrer heimat deutschland
25 milliarden whatsapp nachrichten
konnten nicht gesendet werden 125
millionen in stars stories blieben
ungetestet
53 millionen fotos wurden nicht
hochgeladen bei facebook und da kam das
dann mal kurz das gefühl auf unserem
zusammensein auf dieser erde hat das
nicht geschadet dem ansehen des
betroffenen internetriesen dagegen schon
der soll ja nach den ausfällen spricht
facebook von einer hausgemachten
technikpanne nach einer fehlerhaften
neukonfiguration
sechs stunden lang waren facebook
whatsapp und instagram nicht nutzbar
betroffen waren dreieinhalb milliarden
nutzer der auswahl trifft den us konzern
in schwierigen zeiten vor
kongressabgeordneten erhob eine
ehemalige managerin heute schwere
vorwürfe facebook stelle den profit
systematisch über die sicherheit seiner
nutzer
mehr dazu um 0.50 eben heute journal
update da spricht christina von
ungern-sternberg dann auch mit dem
grünen digital experten konstantin von
notz die erzeugerpreise steigen in
europa weiter rasant und das merken vor
allem die produzenten die viel energie
verbrauchen
egal ob erdgas oder öl die opec will
jetzt zwar ihre fördermengen erhöhen
aber das große aufatmen bleibt aus frank
bethmann an der börse warum ja weil das
nicht reicht das öl kartell müsste den
hahn sehr viel weiter aufdrehen um die
derzeit hohen nachfrage zu befriedigen
vor allem in asien ist der energiehunger
riesengroß das mächtige saudi arabien
allein könnte schnell für abhilfe sorgen
doch warum eigentlich die staaten am
golf um eben jene saudi arabien wollen
die produktion gar nicht drastisch
hochfahren zu gut verdienen sie derzeit
an den hohen weltmarktpreisen und andere
wie russland mexiko nigeria libyen oder
angola können nicht fördern probleme
bemerkbar machen sich die steigenden
ölpreise inzwischen auch bei den lange
zeit wenig beachteten erzeugerpreisen
jetzt aber wo wir mehr und mehr über
inflation sprechen werden die
erzeugerpreise wichtig weil man davon
ausgehen kann dass die hersteller die
teuren preise weitergeben an die
verbraucher die erzeugerpreise also ein
frühindikator der die experten heute
schlucken ließ um über 13 prozent
stiegen die preise ab werk im august
verglichen mit dem vorjahresmonat
vorprodukte wie stahl holz oder beton
verteuerten sich gar um über 14 prozent
und stichwort öl und gas die energie
kosten explodierten in diesem zeitraum
förmlich plus 32 prozent
nicht annähernd so heftig der anstieg
beim dax nach drei tagen im minus aber
endlich wieder heute ein plus von über
einem prozent die verbraucher aber
sollten sich warm anziehen stand jetzt
könnte das ein ziemlich teurer winter
werden danke frank ja den autobauern
machen außerdem fehlende halbleiter zu
schaffen und das schlägt sich deutlich
auf die verkaufszahlen nieder im
september wurden 196
1972 pkw neu zugelassen gut ein viertel
weniger als im vorjahresmonat 17 1
prozent davon waren elektroautos so groß
war ihr anteil noch nie 12,7 prozent
waren plug-in-hybride neue diese kamen
auf 15 9 prozent den größten anteil
machten mit 35,9 prozent benziner aus
und das hier könnte der start einer
steilen karriere sein denn diese rakete
hat nicht nur kosmonauten ins all
gebracht sondern auch eine russische
filmteam nach drei flugstunden
erreichten schauspielerin julia erzählt
und regisseur klinko für die
internationale raumstation wo sie teile
eines kinofilms drehen wollen zusammen
mit zwei echten besatzungsmitgliedern
die sich selbst spielen die geschichte
dazu eine ärztin muss zur iss fliegen um
ein crewmitglied zu retten
bei dem kino jetzt noch das es ist klar
dass wir für künftige generationen jetzt
sehr schnell handeln müssen sagt heute
einer der die moderne klimaforschung
begründet hat der für die menschheit
überhaupt erst die grundlagen legte
damit wir verstehen können was da
passiert wenn die erde sich erwärmt und
wie wir alle dazu beitragen
ohne diese grundlagen wäre weder klar wo
wir jetzt stehen noch was wir jetzt tun
müssen der klimaforscher klaus
hesselmann ist 89 jahre alt er bekommt
dieses jahr gemeinsam mit zwei kollegen
den
physik-nobelpreis christina kreuz stellt
den forscher vor und seine modelle die
uns die augen geöffnet haben sehen
müssen wir selbst
hamburg heute nachmittag das max planck
institut für meteorologie feiert seinen
gründungsdirektor klaus hassel man den
gerade gekürten nobelpreisträger endlich
die verdiente auszeichnung
klaus hesselmann und schumann aber
teilen sich eine hälfte des preises der
italiener giorgio parisi bekommt die
andere für seine forschung zu komplexen
systemen wie das erdklima
solche szenarien hatte hasselmann
vorhergesagt vor jahrzehnten schon
zusammen mit schoko man aber schuf die
voraussetzungen für klimamodelle
zugehört haben nur wenige die fachwelt
wohl die öffentlichkeit ist sicher nicht
das ist heute anders
dass man hier ein problem hatten dass
man langfristig angehen muss das war
eine messe etwas fremd und das hat es
etwas länger gedauert bis die
öffentlichkeit das richtig begriffen hat
und ich persönlich bin sehr dankbar dass
es die jungs ist die also jetzt überall
auf das problem aufmerksam macht
die leute aufzugreifen anzusprechen sehr
viel mehr bewegt als wir immer wieder
unsere wissenschaftliche mitteilung
japan
schon in den 70er jahren entwickelte er
die methoden um den einfluss
menschlicher aktivitäten auf das klima
nachzuweisen und von natürlichen
effekten zu unterscheiden sein kollege
manawi konnte zeigen dass ein erhöhter
kohlendioxid gehalt in der atmosphäre
einen anstieg der temperatur zur folge
hat
ein physik nobelpreis für klimaforschung
das ist eine überraschung für mich
berichtet
jahrelang hatte man ihre warnungen in
den wind geschlagen obwohl sie immer
neue daten vorliegen konnten unermüdlich
mahnte der hamburger forscher sparsam
mit öl und kohle umzugehen sagte eine
zunehmende erderwärmung voraus
bei angenommenen weiteren zunahme der
co2 emissionen wie bisher also in den
kommenden jahrzehnt erwarten wir wenn
wir nichts gegen die emissionen
unternehmen dass wir eine klimaerwärmung
bekommen die etwa der gleiche natürlich
den gleichen größeren aber fast so groß
sein wird wie unterschied zwischen dem
heutigen kriegen oder dessen eiszeit
heute nun die anerkennung für seine
forschung durch seine arbeit es ist es
möglich geworden dass wir heute sagen
können der beobachtete klimawandel wurde
vom menschen verursacht sg handelt sich
um grundlegende physik hier deswegen ist
es der physik-nobelpreis und das auch
gleich ohne herrn hasselmann es arbeit
hätte es das pariser klimaabkommen wie
geben können
der fast 90-jährige setzt jetzt auf die
jungen leute hofft dass sie seinem alten
thema neuen schwung geben
eine große ehrung für drei forscher eine
wichtige mahnung für uns alle und damit
sagen wir zwei danke für heute gerne bis
morgen noch einen schönen abend
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter tiefer luftdruck
bestimmt immer noch das wetter über
deutschland und zwar gibt es zwei
tiefstes eine zieht mit seinem kern
etwas weiter in den norden und das
andere richtung süden und bringt hier an
den alpen teilweise kräftigen regen dann
haben wir es mit zwei hochs zu tun
einmal richtung iberische halbinsel
das schließt zum hoch über russland in
den nächsten tagen auf und so wird es
ruhiger und auch teilweise sonnig
schauen wir in die nacht da haben wir es
mit schauern zu tun im süden regnet es
auch länger nach nordosten hin ist es
erst einmal trocken das war eher
tiefsten temperaturen von sechs grad an
den alpen da ist es am kühlsten und am
mildesten im osten deutschlands mit
zwölf grad morgen im tagesverlauf bilden
sich dann nach westen teils schauer und
auch gewitter sind dabei im süden sind
kräftige schauer ebenfalls unterwegs
nach osten ist es deutlich
aufgelockerter sogar die sonne zeigt
sich damals die temperaturen steigen auf
17 grad dort zehn grad am alpenrand
ja die nächsten tage werden ruhiger mit
den hochs im süden gibt es am donnerstag
noch regen und viele wolken aber sonst
lockert es auf zehn bis 18 grad die
höchstwerte freitag nach nebel
sonnenschein temperaturen bei 12 bis 19
grad und damit ein schöner abend